como es evidente tengo pánico escénico a
diferencia de lo que piensa mucha gente
creen que me es muy fácil hablar en
público y es algo que me aterra
tenía preparada una gran presentación
escrita escribo como hablo generalmente
entonces y siempre de verdad tenido la
buena suerte de tener el papel que voy a
decir para para sentirme segura mirarlo
y listo
tenía un placer hace un poquito más
reducido pero me lo han quitado y
desarmada
y todos cuando les contaba de esta
experiencia me decían lo vas a ser
genial conoces el tema lo sientes lo has
vivido lo has vivido por experiencia
propia y claro que sé del tema porque
porque es una experiencia personal pero
pero me asusta igual hablar en público
entonces si es que no ven muy claramente
en relación lo que estoy diciendo con
las imágenes que estoy pasando como que
no está sucediendo eso por favor
evidentemente esta primera imagen me
remite a una frase que suelo decir mucho
que es que mi droga por elección es la
esperanza y mi medicina la cannabis
si hay algo que quiero que se quede en
ustedes esta tarde sí sí quiero que algo
se lleven esta tarde a sus casas es que
todas y todos merecemos el derecho a
intentar mi nombre es francesca brivio
tengo 39 años desde agosto de 2009 tengo
una enfermedad de las denominadas raras
tan rara que a casi nadie en el mundo
médico le interesa que hay muy poca
información que no las enseñan en las
universidades generalmente o muy por
encima porque somos tan pocos que de
verdad no hay muchos recursos para
investigar la soy comunicadora soy
actriz soy activista soy madre de 3
y creo en la importancia de salir de la
zona de confort que es donde dicen
ocurre la magia
creo en que no podemos esperar a que
venga alguien a hacer los cambios que
queremos nosotras somos alguien nosotras
podemos hacer y ser esos cambios
como les contaba esa es la enfermedad
más trocitos y es una enfermedad de las
células más cositas que están en la
médula ósea esto hace que se incremente
uno de los mediadores es la histamina
entonces mi cuerpo se vuelve un poco
loco y piensa que estoy haciendo lo que
debería estar haciendo
estoy haciendo una reacción alérgica
cuando de verdad no no lo estoy haciendo
entonces se inflaman distintos órganos
esto me ha causado múltiples síntomas
dolores de barriga náuseas vómitos
migrañas fuertísimas debilidad muscular
fibromialgia y un montón de enfermedades
asociadas
visión borrosa depresión ansiedad
a veces déficit de atención generalmente
soy una persona que soy me jacto de ser
multitasking pero a veces me viene este
agobio por la enfermedad que los
mastocitos están dando vueltas en el
cerebro y no puedo pensar claramente no
me acuerdo mi número de teléfono a veces
no puedo escribir la palabra ayer no sé
si va con action o cosas absurdas y me
pasa y me pasa me han hecho un sinfín de
análisis me tatué la palabra aquí para
que ya sepan las enfermeras y donde
tenían que sacar la sangre me hicieron
muchísimos análisis
resonancias biopsias de músculo de
piel
yo veía doctor house en esa época
muchísimo porque tenía la esperanza que
salga mi enfermedad ahí empezó como les
dio en el 2009 entonces veía todos los
capítulos que podía haber si bueno
después que me dieron el diagnóstico
salió más ficción
y bueno más de seis meses sin
diagnóstico
mayo de marzo febrero de 2010 recién me
tuve que ir fuera del país en la clínica
mayo en rochester minnesota para para
ver si me dan un diagnóstico mi
expediente que ya aparecía un libro
baldor dos tomos en la clínica mayo ya
eran tres porque no confían en los
exámenes que han hecho en tu país entre
ese buen hacer todo y finalmente en
marzo de 2010 que tengo esto lo más
parecido a un diagnóstico porque no
están los criterios claros tampoco para
saber si es que esa era la enfermedad o
no pero era lo más parecido a un
desorden en las células más cositas en
médula ósea
empecé estos cambios aparte de peso no
engordo muchísimo por la cortisona que
me inyectaban en grandes cantidades la
ansiedad el no comer no poder andar
estar en silla de ruedas estaba en
andador usado bastón también en otros
momentos de mi enfermedad más bien al
revés no podía provocar probar bocado me
ha llevado hasta la desnutrición
me di cuenta lo rota que estaba en ese
momento me di cuenta que todo lo que yo
creía o daba por sentado no era así está
construida desde un lugar más débil
pensé que era
que era más fuerte antes de eso
pero
fue fue un aprendizaje duro
me desarme como un rompecabezas de un
millón de piezas pensé que nunca voy a
poder volver a armar pero felizmente si
no los seres humanos somos resilientes y
me volví armas acá estoy
y parte de este volverme al mar de salir
adelante fue
todo empezó en el 2013 a finales de 2013
y yo me habían dicho si quería fumar un
cigarrillo de marihuana y dije que sí y
ese día me sentía muy mal estado muy
cansada tenía muchos dolores y fumé y
fue la primera vez que relacione a
alivio
de la enfermedad con la marihuana no
había leído algunos datos de cáncer de
pacientes que fumaban para ciertos
defectos paliativos
pero no tenía esta conciencia fue la
primera vez que asocie y dije oye de
repente si empiezo a fumar empiezo a
aliviar mis síntomas yo nunca había sido
una fumadora habitual de cannabis
había formado de chica y había fumado
varias veces contrario a los mitos que
suelen decir decirse no me volvió una
mona
y al contrario no me ser más ni siquiera
un cigarrillo de marihuana entonces
estaba como no sabía cómo hacerlo
pero igual creo que la marihuana
cannabis recreativo que aunque siempre
se usa recretivo yo creo que es
terapéutico cuando se usa de manera
recreativa
no es una lucha en la que yo estoy
enfocada porque creo que estos son
libertades individuales no tengo nada
moral en contra al contrario eso creo
que es una libertad individual pero la
lucha que de verdad me compete la que a
mí me subleva la que me hace exigirle al
estado reacción y sobre todo acción es
la lucha por el cannabis medicinal
para mediados de 2014 yo tomaba había
estado tomando 27 pastillas al día
como les comenté mi enfermedad no tiene
cura a veces se tiene que tratar con
agentes quimioterapéuticos con
interferón su forma más agresiva es
mortal no te mueres
para algunos doctores también te dicen
que de repente toman un antihistamínico
al día puedes vivir hasta ahora no ha
conocido a nadie los grupos de pacientes
que sólo tomando antihistamínicos pueda
vivir pero para mediados de junio de
2014 decidí dejar tomar todo todo
absolutamente todo está harta de tomar
remedios que no me remedian nada empecé
un trabajo introspección o tomar otras
plantas sagradas también y enfocarme y
tratar de sanar yo y me acordé lo que
esto pues que la marihuana me había
caído bien el 2013 me había aliviado y
empecé a fumar de manera habitual dos
toques en la mañana dos toques en la
noche podía hacer mis actividades pero
depende de la hierba que me llevaran a
mi casa de digamos era los efectos no a
veces me da un poquito más de sueño para
dosificar la era difícil para algo que
para mí era un tema medicinal no
entonces decidí que
antes de decidir eso en el 2000 enero
2016 deje de tomar el cannabis también
porque me cansaba el hábito de fumar lo
y sentía eso como les dije que no lo
podía dosificar
entonces por esas cosas de la vida
decidí investigar investigar e
investigar y llegué a saber más sobre el
cannabis medicinal en aceite
no sabía dónde conseguirlo era era muy
difícil estafa mucho no hay una
información informada
sentía que el estado me había
desamparado que me obligaba a delinquir
pero como bien dice la doctora paola
pinedo no es una doctora colombiana la
desobediencia civil a veces es
importante no porque una ley sea ley
quiere decir que sea justa creo que la
ética está más allá de las leyes muchas
veces
entonces empecé este camino gracias a
que tres más mujeres actrices me
regalaron dos botellitas de aceite de
buena calidad porque había probado por
ahí algunas cosas sino no me habían
hecho el efecto esperado y estas tres
capas me regalaron dos botellitas de
aceite y yo les había dicho por favor
que no tenga thc en el cannabis tiene
muchos psicoactivos cannabinoides perdón
y el thc es el conocido el psicoactivo
no entonces yo les había dicho por favor
que no tengas thc porque yo no quiero
estar esto no repetía con la ignorancia
que que a veces uno tiene la confianza
que te da la ignorancia a veces no
entonces yo les había dicho pero tomé un
poquito de las gotas y sentí el afecto
el efecto del thc en mi cuerpo sentí un
relajo sentí como estaba en todo mi
cuerpo
investigando supe que el thc si es
medicinal no solo es la parte que te
pone esto no hay'
dentro de los ciento cuarenta y tantos
cannabinoides que existe es que está el
cb del thc el cbn cvg el thc era algo
muy importante para mi tratamiento
apenas tome un par de gotas sentir
alivio ese dolor el año pasado que me
había empezado de nuevo la enfermedad
muy muy muy agresivamente que pensé que
de repente ésta era como la última
batalla porque estaba en desnutrición y
muchas cosas sentí el alivio del dolor
que sentía en el estómago del de cabeza
comenzó a pesarle a tolerarla la comida
y eso
y empecé a tolerar la comida poco a poco
me hizo
me hizo sentir bien
no sólo y una de las cosas que decíamos
viendo la imagen me acordaba una de las
cosas que decíamos de se dice el thc es
que es el psicoactivo como si el
psicoactivo tener 5 actividad fuera algo
malo cuando no tomo un café tiene 5
actividad cuando uno se siente feliz
tiene psico actividad cuando uno siente
el amor tiene psico actividad
felizmente puede investigar más y llegue
a personas increíbles que saben
muchísimo del tema conoce más de rafael
meshulam si pueden ver un documental que
se llama the scientist que explican
mucho sobre el sistema en lo que han
habido de distintas cosas se les
recomiendo cuando sí para gordon
cristina sánchez manuel guzmán y sant
ruso
paola pinedo
comencé a viajar y aprender más sobre
esto y las seminarios
y empecé a pensar que si yo una
ciudadana de a pie comunicadora podía
tener acceso a esta información me da
muchísima rabia que el mucha gente del
mundo científico no lo hiciese no que
tantos doctores o médicos les dieran
como un poco no sé desde flojera de digo
yo pero supe saber el súper del sistema
endocannabinoide que es algo que que
muchísimas personas no saben no todos
tenemos receptores de cannabis en
nuestro organismo todos los humanos y
todos los mamíferos por eso funciona tan
bien y yo siempre digo eso no es no es
magia no hay que tener pensamiento
mágico religioso me va a funcionar el
cannabis no es química tenemos sistema
endocannabinoide hay receptores de
cannabis en nuestra sangre y por eso
funciona también y por eso es en todo
nuestro organismo pero no es en tallo
cerebral que es donde controlan los
latidos y la respiración por eso no hay
muerte por cannabis por eso es una
medicina tan segura
también conocido el efecto séquito que
es lo que les decía hace un momento que
toda la planta junta es como mejor
funciona sin aislar sólo uno de sus
componentes la naturaleza sabia no no
tenemos que intervenirla y retirar solo
uno todos juntos funciones es el efecto
se quito
una buena medicina no solo te hace bien
a ti sino también a tu entorno a tu
familia creo que todas y todos tenemos
el derecho a intentar a tener una vida
digna
yo no solo uso el aceite de cannabis que
lo uso en la mañana y en la noche sino
también vapor hizo eso mira utilizador
ahí se pone se deshidrata la cannabis y
lo tomas para los picos para las
emergencias las urgencias el cannabis
funciona en vaporizador funciona muy
bien no es un dato que yo he inventado
se usa en los países de alta vigilancia
sanitaria en canadá en alemania es otra
de las formas médicas el vaporizar que
es distinto a la combustión que es
cuando fumas un cigarrillo de cannabis
el thc se vuelve más psicoactivo
mientras más calor tenga entonces cuando
tú fumas un cigarrillo el cannabis está
expandiendo elevando el efecto
psicoactivo digamos cuando vaporiza sólo
llegas a 200 grados más o menos los
otros 800 900 grados es por eso que se
siente tanto la potencia
por el prohibicionismo por el
oscurantismo
hemos perdido vidas cuantas personas aún
estarían aquí cuantos podrían haber
tenido el libio
esta historia el prohibicionismo por
favor búsquenlo en internet
enciclopedias solo vino por cosas
racistas clasistas por poderes
económicos
el lado ms en el 2016 reconoció que no
habían hecho estudios sobre el cannabis
no la organización mundial de la salud
recién lo han hecho y res para el
próximo año van a salir los resultados y
todo parece indicar que van a ser
bastante favorecedoras para todos
nosotros que usamos cannabis medicinal
entonces es importante saber que el
prohibicionismo cuesta vidas
ese soy yo empoderadas con esta imagen
porque la información es poder con
empecé a saber más a leer más me comencé
a sentir mejor comencé a entender por
qué funcionaba en mi organismo y cómo
podía yo tener mucho más fuerzas para
poder ayudar a otras personas porque la
salud no espera
no son re fríos de diarreas de las que
estamos hablando
es algo crónico o terminal entonces nos
surge que esto se reglamente de la mejor
manera y lo más rápido
porque eso es porque una buena medicina
no solo te hace bien a ti sino a tu
familia yo gracias a cannabis medicinal
cannabis puedo estar aquí puedo estar
hablándole a ustedes puedo sentarme a
compartir una mesa con la gente que
quiero puedo salir a pasear puedo viajar
puedo puedo ser puedo hacer me siento
bien
yo tenía fatiga crónica
y bueno ahí nuestro amigo nos está
contando que es un caso de la vida real
es un taxista que me llevo y me contó
que estaba tomando aceite de cannabis él
su esposa y su hija por distintas cosas
y que todos les estaba yendo muy muy
bien entonces lo invite a subir a
nuestra sesión de fotos
como decía una buena medicina nos hace
bien a todos
bien
y bueno y ya que me sentía tan bien y
con tanta energía y con ganas de
retribuir un poco a lo que yo siento que
se me ha dado porque soy privilegiada
porque tengo mucho amor a mi alrededor
porque siento el respaldo de tantísimas
personas y porque en el 2009 cuando yo
estuve muy enferma y tuve que viajar
muchísima gente ayudó se hicieron muchas
fiestas profundos conciertos
exposiciones de artes y se recaudó
dinero y con ese dinero yo pude viajar
yo sentía siempre que necesitaba
devolverle a la sociedad lo que me había
dado entonces en él empecé a pensar que
es él y cuando pasó lo del cannabis dije
quiero que nadie se sienta tan sola como
yo una vez me sentí no quiero que se
sientan desamparados porque no hay
información generalmente correcta y
porque el estado nos tenía tanto tiempo
en verse abandonados
cannabis gotas de esperanza es una
asociación sin fines de lucro que busca
dar esa esperanza para que nadie tenga
que pasar un vía crucis con distintas
medicinas hasta que se entere de
cannabis medicinal no tiene que ser la
última opción es una medicina muy segura
y es lo que más le debería importar a
los doctores y a las doctoras que una
medicina sea segura si es que no
funciona pueden tratar lo que sea pero
lo que vamos a defender en cannabis
gotas de esperanza es el uso informado
no el derecho a intentar damos charlas
para aparato médico a veces solamente
para científicos para público en general
tenemos bueno hemos ayudado también a
unas universidades un programa que se
llama edu cannabis que vamos y les
explicamos sobre los usos de cannabis
medicinal tenemos un doctor canadiense
que es un consultor externo de nuestra
asociación y que viene y también da
charlas porque la información es
importante no nos hace sentir bien
seguros y que todo lo que yo le estoy
diciendo que espero que me lo cuestionen
cuando lleguen a sus casas busquen
información sobre sobre lo que estoy
hablando como cannabis gotas esperanza
nos unimos a la fecam en que es la
federación de cannabis medicinal nos
dimos cuenta que unidas éramos más
fuertes
y que teníamos que llevar nuestra voz a
a la ministra la ministra de salud
queremos que se implemente correctamente
la ley la ley ya salió el año pasado
pero está el reglamento
salió una primera edición en mayo muy
mal hecho con gente prohibicionista en
la mesa que no tiene no tiene sentido de
estar ahí no en la ley el objeto de la
ley es el acceso entonces hay gente que
está en contra de cosas cannabis
medicinal no no se puede obtener un
acceso entonces entre came cannábicos de
la esperanza peleamos mucho por eso esta
es la ministra de salud que se
comprometió a hacer muchos casos de
muchas cosas importantes que habíamos
hecho llegar en este documento de
reglamento alterno también hacemos
campañas de sensibilización a la
sociedad civil esta campaña se llamó
acceso real para que la gente entienda
cómo por qué siguen discutiendo si ya
salió la ley bueno la ley como les digo
el reglamento no iba a permitir
realmente el acceso usted dice que esto
empezó por las pacientes y por las
madres de pacientes y es verdad si no
fuera por esas madres que han luchado
que siembran en sus casas que preparan
la medicina para la medicina pero sus
hijos probablemente no estaríamos aquí
mi agradecimiento siempre para ellas
pero si bien empezó así no tiene por qué
terminar así yo creo que el estado
médicos médicas
sociedad civil empresa privado todos
podríamos trabajar para que salga esta
ley de la mejor manera y nos podamos
beneficiar todos en ese papel dice hacer
porque por un tiempo tenía ese papel
frente a mi cama para levantarme y
acordarme que tengo que hacer no sólo
pensar sino hacer y distinto a lo que se
suele creer una de las cosas que se les
marca a la cannabis es que tiene el
síndrome de síndrome amor a motor a
motivación al que es que te quedas todo
el día tirada en tu cama no sí estoy
relajada
yo ya no quiero hacer nada y es mentira
o sea yo desde que uso cannabis
medicinal yo tenía fatiga crónica como
les digo me levantaba tardísimo me
costaba muchísimo hacer y ahora no tengo
muchísima energía y aparte de lo que le
he contado que estoy haciendo con
cannabis gotas de esperanza de ser madre
de 3
estoy metida en tres proyectos más
firmar un contrato con un pingüino
randomhouse es una editora para escribir
un libro de cannabis medicinal estamos
haciendo
unos consultorios en las clínicas para
proyectos para atender a personas y
aparte hacer una medicina otra vez para
hacer una medicina de calidad entonces
de ninguna manera creo que se le puede
decir que ahora estoy más relajada sin
hacer nada relajada de ánimo no podría
haber hecho esto de lo que estoy
haciendo si no tuviera un equipo genial
inés que es mi brazo derecho izquierdo
ella cuando le dije que estaba buscando
alguien para que se una porque principio
decía todo yo sola necesitaba a alguien
le dije inaes me dijo ella
necesitas alguien que te asista y elige
no necesito alguien que se enamore de
esto que crea como yo creo que le
apasione como me apasiona y así fue así
que si no fuera por ella yo ni siquiera
estaría para acá porque me moría de
nebrija de terrible y me ayudado es ver
esto me ha aguantado toda la semana
quejándome también un consejo directivo
increíble superlativo consultor un
consejo consultivo a mi hermano que si
no hubiera sido por él no hubiera podido
empezar la asociación porque si ni tan
mínimo dos personas les agradezco que
haya querido meterse en esto y por
supuesto
sin mis hijos y mis crías y mis tres
crías no podría estar haciendo todo lo
que hago porque como dicen me faltan
horas al día y muchas veces llego tarde
a la casa y
y por el respeto que sienten por mí y
por el trabajo por la empatía porque
entienden que lo que estamos haciendo es
mucho más grande que nosotras esto
podría potencialmente beneficiar a 7
millones de peruanas y peruanos quizás
más entonces es importante que salga
esta ley bien para cerrar
creo que la vida puede obligarme a
muchas cosas pero
pero no me van a obligar a rendirme
nunca y como escuchar una vez creo que
lo único lo único más fuerte que el
miedo es la esperanza gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]